in triangle ABC above a be this whole
sex this length of this segment is equal
to AC e is the midpoint of a B well they
really haven't drawn this to scale let
me see if I can draw a little bit more
to scale so they're saying e is the
midpoint of a B so the midpoint looks
closer to around there so it'll look
like this which is a this is e this is B
that is D and then that is C so let me
mark this off so E is the midpoint of a
B so that means AE is equal to e b and d
is the midpoint of AAC and we know that
AC is the same length as a be so ad is
going to be so this is going to be the
same length as that which is also the
same length as that which is the same
length as that if a e is equal to X so
ie so this distance right over here is
equal to X and Ed is equal to 4 so let
me mark so this is Ed is equal to 4 so
this is this length of the segment right
over here is for what is the length of
BC what is the length of BC here now the
key thing that might jump out at you is
that we're dealing with two similar
triangles that triangle AED is similar
to triangle a b c and how do we know
that they're similar well their
corresponding sides have the same ratio
the ratio AC is twice ad a B is twice a
and then they have a then they have a
common angle in between so AED is
similar to triangle ABC let me write
this down so triangle AED is similar
similar to triangle ABC ABC and that
what that tells this is the ratio
between corresponding sides is going to
be the same now bc is the corresponding
side on the larger triangle on triangle
ABC to this side side ed
on the smaller triangle on triangle AED
now what's the ratio between
corresponding sides of ABC and AED well
this is this length is X we've already
been told that this length we know is 2x
how do we know that because he is the
midpoint so the ratio between the larger
the corresponding sides of the larger
triangle and the smaller triangle the
ratio is 2x 2x or the ratio is just too
so the ratio or another way of saying it
is the corresponding side of the larger
triangle is twice the corresponding side
of the shorter of the smaller triangle
so if this is for this is going to be
twice for it's going to be eight sobeys
the length of segment BC is eight